Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, alle Rebecca sind ja nicht, Rebecca gelb, Rebecca grün, Rebecca blau, fake Rebecca, Rebecca blau, Rebecca gelb, Rebecca blühen, aber die Rebecca gefällt mir! Rebecca sagt... Orgel! Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, Rebecca, und Rebecca! Ihr grosser Rebecca-Podcast. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Ufo. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. An meiner Seite. Stefan Dietze. Florian Willis ist auch am Start. Er hat es geschafft. Mega, tolles Intro. Ja, danke, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Türaufmacher von Mike, der diese Folge offiziell zur Rebecca-Folge gemacht hat. Wir widmen diese Folge allen Rebeccas dieser Welt. Nochmal. Nochmal, ja. Und nochmal, wir haben gar nicht die Chance, noch alle anderen Namen auch aufzuholen. So viel, wie wir Rebecca schon gegeben haben. Ich hoffe, irgendwer in der Zukunft macht sich mal die Arbeit, alle Folgen zu dem Intro zu packen. Ist ja wie so ein großes Memory-Spiel gerade. Ja, das stimmt. Wozu es auch eigentlich gehört. Genau, weil es gibt immer so einen acht bis neun Folgen Delay, wo es dann eigentlich dazu passen müsste. Ja, oh Gott.
Aber super, tolles Intro. Super.
Also alle Rebeccas, die Aufmerksamkeit von allen Rebeccas
haben wir jetzt. Ich glaube, das ist eine Zielgruppe, die auch
reicht. Also man sagt ja immer, wenn du so ein Geschäft
aufmachst, wenn nur ein Prozent
der Bevölkerung dein Produkt
liebt, dann sind das ja schon
800.000 Menschen,
das ist ja schon, reicht ja schon. Dem liegt halt immer
zugrunde, dass man alle Menschen erreicht. Dass man dieses Segen erreicht. Das ist ein unbegrenztes Marketing-Budget hat. Naja. Unser CFO von Tietze und Will redet von Büjo. Ja, nee, Leute, da haben wir nicht das Büjo für. Das ist übrigens unser CFO, Stefan Tietze. Nee, wirklich. Also wir können ja nicht noch einen Büjo-Topf aufnehmen. Sonst bricht ja alles zusammen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich glaube, wenn du wirklich ein Produkt vermarktest nur für Rebeccas auf der Welt, das reicht. Ich glaube, das reicht wirklich. Wenn du wirklich weltweit alle ansprichst, dann kannst du es schaffen. Guter Beweis ist ja diese Folge hier, die durch die Decke gegangen hat. Es sind achtmal so viele Hörerinnen hauptsächlich als sonst, weil alle Rebeccas der Welt zumindest mal sagen, da höre ich jetzt mal rein. Ja, man kann ja bei Spotify, das machen ja auch alle, gehen, machen so Deep Dives in ihre Statistics. Und da kann man ja wirklich gucken, wo erreicht man wen. Und ich glaube, das machen andere Podcaster noch gewissenhafter als wir. Wir sollten mal reingehen, weil ich glaube, inzwischen kann man auch einfach mal gucken, welche Namen man erreicht. Wahnsinnig viele Niklas, gar keine Pauls mehr. Null Pauls. Die sind wirklich auf null runtergegangen. Nee, weil ich glaube, Pauls werden, das ist eine spannende Theorie, wird man so wie der Name ist. Wird man so ein bisschen so wie der Name so geriert. Es gibt ja bestimmt mehr Schreiner, die Zimmermann heißen, als Zimmermänner, die Schreiner heißen. Als Zimmermänner, die Schreiner heißen. Nein, es gibt mehr Zimmermänner, die Schreiner sind, als Astronauten. Lass mich kurz mal zu Ende denken. Es ist früh am Morgen, Stefan Tietze ist noch müde.
Als zum Beispiel Werners, Familie Werners, die Schreiner innehaben in der Familie. Verstehst du? Man ist, wie man heisst. Also immer wenn du ein Autohaus von Werner Brumm siehst, dann weißt du, okay, da war einfach schon die Karriere angelegt. Ich möchte doch einfach nur Du bist, was du ist ergänzen. Du bist, wie du heisst. Um die Zusatzklausel, Coda, Klammer auf, Du bist, was du heisst. Ja, wir sind ja eh gerade dabei, alle Sprichwörter der Welt neu zu ordnen. Ja, also 2022 ist der Moment, wo alles nochmal neu geschüttelt wird. Jan Gustafsson dankenswerterweise hat schon unsere Revolution der Schachsprichwörter aufgegriffen. Ehrenbürger. Der Springer am Rand bringt Kummer und Schand, das ist natürlich ein schlechtes Sprichwort, weil Kummer und Schand, Rand, da weiß man nicht genau, welche Figur gemeint ist. Deswegen haben wir gesagt, am Rand ein Pferd ist nichts wert und er hat das ab jetzt auch schon offiziell so eingesetzt. Vielen, vielen Dank dafür, aber da ist noch viel zu machen. Vor allem hat der Deutsche Schachbund dazu auch die, auf der Ordnung, ich lese es kurz vor, hat auf der offiziellen Website vom Schachbund sind wir aufgetaucht. Wirklich? Und zwar stand da, im Zug 22 entwickelte Hannah Marie allerdings ihre Springer an den Rand und der alte Merkspruch, ein Springer am Rand bringt Kummer und Schrand, ist inzwischen durchgestrichrichen worden und ergänzt um am Rand steht ein Pferd, das ist gar nichts wert, sollte sich Elisabethi bewahrheiten. Das heißt, auf der offiziellen Website vom Deutschen Schachbund wurde der jetzt durchgestrichen und jeweils ersetzt durch am Rand steht ein Pferd, das ist gar nichts wert. Und da seht ihr es wieder, man kann die Welt tatsächlich verändern, es lohnt sich für Veränderung zu kämpfen, es funktioniert am Ende. Also Micromanagement. Also so micro, wir sind auf dem Deutschen Schachbund. Aber ist damit die Storyline von Stefan und Schach abgeschlossen? Weil dein großer Traum war es ja, auf dem Cover eines Schachmagazins zu sein, dem Rösselsprung. Aber das hat nicht geklappt bisher, aber das ist ja immerhin schon mal etwas. Bist du damit zufrieden? Es geht noch weiter. Ich möchte nur so viel verraten, es geht in diesem Jahr gehörig weiter. wie es weitergeht. Also in diesem Jahr kommt noch etwas, da können sich alle sehr drauf freuen oder halt auch nicht, je nachdem wie sie diese Storyline bewerten. Da liegt noch was in der Schublade von Stefan, habe ich es gesagt. Da liegt eine Menge, da liegen Flugtickets in der Schublade. Ich bin jetzt eingestiegen, ich habe ein neues Hobby und zwar bin ich großer Formel-1-Affizionado. Nein, nein. Und zwar habe ich auf Netflix Drive to Survive die beste fucking Serie aller Zeiten. Und das beste Marketing aller Zeiten. Vor allem interessiert mich null für Formel 1. Ich check das nicht, aber es ist einfach super interessant zu schauen. Und da ist mir aufgefallen am Rande, dass mittlerweile man nicht mehr sagt, don't drink and drive. Weil auf diesen ganzen Strecken, diese ganzen Formel 1-Strecken steht immer gross drüber when you drive, never drink.
Wo ich mir auch dachte, da ist auch
eine Revolution durchgegangen, weil ich bin immer
aufgewachsen mit don't drink and drive,
das war für mich immer ein feststehender
Satz und der anscheinend hat man irgendwann
gesagt, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nee, when you drive,
if you,
if you, consider driving,
don't even think about drinking a pint. Ja, weil es ist weniger schmissig geworden, aber direkter. Never drink, when you drive, if you... Ich weiß genau, worauf du Bezug nimmst, und zwar nimmst du auf die Heineken 0,0% Werbung. Ach so, ich dachte, das wäre ein genereller Ausruf.
Nee, das steht immer auf der Strecke, das wird gesponsert, die Formel 1 unter anderem von Heineken, und das ist deren Slogan für deren 0,0 Bier. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, warum die das andere nicht genommen haben, entweder weil sie eine uncatchy leihen wollten, glaube ich nicht, oder Don Drink and Drive ist marketingrechtlich geschützt von irgendwem. Wow. Aber da dachte ich nämlich, ich dachte die ganze Zeit, die Serie, dieses ganze Rumgebrumme da und die Motoren interessiert mich nicht. Ich dachte die halbe Serie nur, warum haben die das geändert? Was war der Anstoss, dass sie gemerkt haben, marketingtechnisch Don't Drink and Drive funktioniert nicht mehr. Aber anscheinend funktioniert es noch, deswegen... Ja hier, Don't Drink and Drive ist eine Kampagne. Ich glaube, so etwas wie eine staatliche Kampagne. Und deswegen wahrscheinlich sind da Marken und Bildrechte schon vergeben. Und deswegen kann man das Heineken, diesen uncatchy Slogan, If you are driving, if you are ever going to be in a car, please don't consider drinking at all. Und ich meine, gibt es in der gesamten englischen Sprache keinen Reim?
Du mit deinen Reimen. Ich meine, wenn du sowas schon machst, irgendwie, if you drink, never think, so, so, if, you don't thrive when you drink and drive.
Sowas zum Beispiel, ja, you put your life in a knife if you drink and drive.
Vielen Dank. you drink and drive. So was zum Beispiel. Ja, you put your life in a knife if you drink and drive. So was in der Ecke. Ja, das ist nämlich auch ein Schachspruch. Night on E5 will thrive. The night on E5 will thrive. Stark. Der ist, naja, auch nicht gut. Kann ja auch sein. Kann ja auch was anderes möglich sein. Aber vielleicht können wir uns kombinieren mit diesem Drink-and-Drive-Ting. Ich glaube, da kann man auch noch enger zusammenarbeiten auf jeden Fall. Aber nee, tolle Serie. Ich bin ja eher auf der Suche nach einem neuen Hobby, aber nichts will so richtig hängenbleiben. Aber es ist schon spannend, weil die Formel 1 hatte ja seit Jahren ein großes Problem. Leute sind abgesprungen, haben es nicht mehr verfolgt. Klar war es auch nicht hilfreich, dass Mercedes so wahnsinnig erfolgreich war und kein guter Wettbewerb zustande kam, das Überholen war schwierig, die Strecken wurden moderner und deswegen konnte man auch nicht mehr gut überholen, bla bla bla bla.
Grosses Marketingproblem. So, und dann haben die natürlich ein großes Rebranding gemacht mit einem coolen, catchy neuen Theme-Song, der immer vor allem ein Rennen beginnt, ein komplettes If you drive, never keep drinking, if you're driving, never keep drinking, look at, look at Susie, she's now dead, dead, she's dead, dead, dead, dead, Formel 1. Aber es ist ein, ja und dann, was haben sie geändert dann? So und dann haben sie, genau, Logo, alles rebranded. Formel 2 wäre doch vielleicht meine Idee. Ja, haben sie auch gemacht, Formel 2 und Form-3 haben sie auch gemacht. Und dann natürlich Drive to Survive an den Start gebracht auf Netflix, eine Serie. Und ich kenne inzwischen mehr Formel-1-Fans, die sehr moderne Formel-1-Fans sind, weil sie von Drive to Survive kommen, als Leute, die vorher schon dabei waren. Es ist super, vor allem ist es ein komplett bescheuerter Sport, also es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und vor allem ist es ganz oft meine Lieblingsabfolge an Ereignissen immer, hier ist dieser junge neue Fahrer, er kommt irgendwo aus der Armut, seine Eltern haben das gesamte Geld zusammengesammelt, damit er endlich mal fahren darf und jetzt wurde er von diesem Rennstall angeheuert, der eh schon der Underdog ist und er gibt alles und er trainiert jeden Tag und alles steckt er nur da rein und es ist sein großer Traum und er fährt los und in Runde zwei sieht man so sein Auto und er fährt und hört sich BAM
und reißt irgendwo auf,
irgendwo eine Explosion am Auto,
er fährt rechts ran, das Rennen ist vorbei.
Und man denkt sich, das ist jetzt der dramaturgische
Bogen, dieser arme junge
Fahrer fährt irgendwo nach
Madrid irgendwo, ist irgendwo in der
Welt, wo er nicht aufgewachsen ist, hängt
da wahrscheinlich wochenlang rum, bereitet sich ewig auf sein Rennen vor, nur um dann nach vier Minuten BAM und er fährt rechts ran und alles klar, ich stecke aus, ciao.
Ich will auch noch mal gut, meistens ist der Schnitt ja, wenn jemand was passiert ist, ist der Schnitt ja schon, passiert ja nach dem Unfall. Das heisst, du hast ein Rennen, Rennen, Rennen und dann gibst du Schnitt und dann siehst du ihn in der Wandstecken, in dieser Schaumwand und dann ist alles gut immer, aber der Schnitt ist so lustig, weil er so brachial ist und dann hast du hinten so ein Blinklicht an und der hängt so in der Wand. Aber auch bei den technischen Effekten sieht man auch so, wenn die Musik ausgeht und man sieht nur das Auto so in der Gerade fahren und du weißt schon, gleich reißt irgendwas ab, gleich fliegt irgendwas in die Luft, niemand weiss was und die fahren ran und sagen, tschau, ich gehe nach Hause. Es ist einfach komplett bescheuert. Aber ja, das gehört ja so. Aber wie tief bist du drin? Folge drei. Ah, okay. Von der ersten Staffel. Ja, ich bin jetzt drin, ich schaue es in der Badewanne an. Okay. Fühle ich mich warm und wohlig und sicher. Wurm. Fühle ich mich wie so ein schöner Wurmkäse drin. Einfach so überall essen. Was ist eigentlich, kam eine grosse Frage bei uns im Reddit, die trage ich mal von der Community nun zu dir, was ist aus der grossen Stromrechnungs Storyline geworden? Kein Kommentar. Wozu ich was sagen kann, ist, ob es schon weiter geht mit der Kratzergeschichte. Lawsuit pending. Noch bin ich nicht im Krankenhaus, noch hat mich die Gewalt nicht eingeholt, die Berliner Faust. Ah. Die Kratzergeschichte, die 400-Euro-Geschichte. Noch kam nichts. Also ich bin sicher, keine Konsequenzen bisher. Okay. Okay. Alles gut. Mir geht's gut. Ich bin gut, ich bin gut dabei. Ich habe ein bisschen Sorgen gemacht. Ich war ja nicht in Köln und hätte dir nicht helfen können, wenn jetzt der Anruf gekommen wäre um Mitternacht. Aber du warst abfahrtbereit. Also wenn ich dich angevenmaut hätte, hättest du sofort sagen können, okay, spring los ins Titzemobil. Ich gehe kurz in den Zug und binnen sechs Stunden kann ich in Köln sein. Wir sehen uns. Ja, ich war beruflich in Zürich, habe da mit einem Kumpel an einem neuen Projekt gearbeitet. Und das Coolste, was jemals mir passiert ist, ist passiert. Ich bin gerade wieder so ein bisschen auf Rammstein gestossen, habe ich ja schon auch hier im Podcast erzählt, weil ich diese Dokumentation entdeckt habe und bin dann quasi vom Arbeiten zurück zum Hotel gefahren abends und komme mit dem Roller vorbei, einem Riesenstadion, wo plötzlich Musik zu hören ist und wo man eine Bässe und die ganze Strasse war im Beben und selbst draußen im Stadion standen ganz, ganz viele Menschen und da waren noch so Bierstände aufgebaut und so aussieht für die Menschen draußen und ich machte die Köpfehörer ab, auf denen glaube ich Rammstein lief, um Rammstein zu hören. Geht nahtlos weiter der Song. Es geht nahtlos weiter und dann war halt halt in diesem Stadion, hat Rammstein ein Konzert gespielt, vor 50.000 Menschen, ein riesiges Konzert. Und ich habe mich dann daneben gestellt, habe mir dann ein Bier geholt, habe mich daneben gestellt, neben das Stadion, wo es genauso laut war, das Konzert, wie jegliche Konzerte, die ich mal so gesehen habe. War auch gut, ich stand niemandem im Weg mit meiner Größe. Also das ist, glaube ich, der richtige. Alle grossen Menschen standen draußen, außerhalb des Stadions. Und es war so kristallklar zu hören, es war so unglaublich laut. Und ich hatte die beste Zeit, weil Rammstein ist ja vor allem bekannt für die Irren-Pyro-Shows, was irre war. Und dann habe ich mich aber auch gefragt, weil ich habe alles ja gesehen, wie es im Stadion plötzlich die Flammen hochschießen und dachte mir, ist jetzt meine Fear of Missing Out, ist die eigentlich jetzt größer bei einem Rammstein-Konzert? Ja. Weil du noch so siehst, was die für eine Megashow in der Halle abfeuern und du siehst so nebenan und Leute schreien und sagen, wow, sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen. Wo kommt das Feuer her? Wo passiert das denn? Wo geht das los?
Oder ist es zumindest besser, weil man noch was sehen kann,
die Flammen oder das Feuerwerk über dem Stadion,
als jetzt bei einem Ed Sheeran-Konzert,
wo man nur in einer Menge immer einen Song zu Ende spielen hört und dann alle, uh, wie er so ...
Wo man nur die Teenie-Tränen riecht dann die ganze Zeit.
Ja, aber es war irre.
Wahnsinn.
Das war so cool, da hab ich anderthalb Stunden
vorm Stadion gestanden.
Aber ist das nicht Diebstahl?
Hast du den nicht schlecht gefühlt ein bisschen? Jetzt waren auch Polizisten da, wo ich dachte so, warum sind die, was machen die jetzt hier? Weil es ist illegal, sich ein Stadion zu erschleichen. Aber dann müssten die ganz Zürich verhaften. Ja gut, dann sind die aber selber schuld, wenn die so laut spielen. Ja, habe ich auch gehört. Die müssen ja sagen, naja, müsst ihr aber auch leiser spielen, wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass die ganze Stadt euch hört. Genau, am zweiten Abend war ich dann ganz woanders in der Stadt und da habe ich die auch noch gehört, das war wirklich am anderen ganzen Ende der Stadt, das heißt, die haben wirklich einfach ganz Zürich beschallt, das fand ich ganz fantastisch. Das gibt es ja auch so bei manchen Konzerthäusern, so Sinfonien, dass irgendwie neben dem Gebäude so ein Lautsprecher ist, wo man das Konzert hört, das gerade drinnen stattfindet und ich fand immer die Vorstellung so toll, dass sich davor so eine Traube von Menschen in Frack und Abendkleid versammeln, die noch versuchen, dann irgendwie lang lang zu hören und dann einfach da sich so rumscharen. Mit so dicken Decken und so einem heißen Thema. Ja, spiel das Gräuchten, spiel es! Die einfach da dieses bisschen Suppe da raus saugen, das da noch aus der Wand kommt. Ich fand es immer einmal sehr unangenehm. Wir haben einmal früher, einer unserer erbärmlichen Konzerte mit der Band war an der Kirche, am Weihnachtsmarkt, die ging einmal rum, der ganze Weihnachtsmarkt ging einmal um die Kirche herum. Und das heißt, unsere Bühne stand am einen Ende, aber dann wurden Boxen aufgestellt, so dass man auch hinter der Kirche uns noch hören konnte. Das fand ich ganz, ganz blöd. Weil ich meine, wir waren jetzt nicht für unseren kristallklaren Sound und unsere engelsgleichen Stimmen bekannt, sondern eher dann schon für, naja, wir machen so ein bisschen Faxen auf der Bühne und Gags. Aber wenn man das nicht sieht, sondern dann irgendwo am Ende hinter der Kirche steht und sich die ganze Zeit fragt, woher diese Musik kommt, weil die denken ja, die wissen ja nicht, dass eine Band spielt, sondern die dachten die ganze Zeit, da läuft irgendeine weirde Live-CD von einer Schülerband. Wie nervig, also unglaublich nervig. Deswegen, vielleicht weiss Ramstein das gar nicht, also in diesem Sinne, man hat euch auch vom Stadion gehört. Nee, von Kollege zu Kollege, gibst du mal weiter. Ich denke, du hast ja beim Konzert immer gesagt, so, Leute, wir sind hier in der Kirche auf der Bühne übrigens, wir sind hier auf der Bühne, wir sind direkt hier, drehen Sie sich mal um,
Don't Drink and Drive,
Don't Glühwein, Drink and Drive,
Never Glühwein while you're driving.
Und jetzt kommt
unser nächster Song, Don't Glüh the
Don't Glüh the Wine. Okay.
So hieß ein Song von euch?
Don't Glüh the Wine while driving.
Stark. Stark? Ja, das war stark.
Nee, richtig toll. Da hatte ich einen richtig schönen Abend, weißt du das? Und dann bin ich lustigerweise auch mit dem Tinnitus ins Bett gegangen. Och, komm mal. Obwohl ich vor einem Stadion stand, das war fantastisch. Wahnsinn. Die haben einen Sound. Aber so muss es doch sein, nach einem richtigen Konzert, oder? Nach einem richtigen Konzert muss es so sein. Ja. Du bist kein Konzertgänger, oder? Nee. Weil ich habe auch wieder gedacht, es gibt doch nichts besseres als die Musik, die man mag, live zu hören, von den Leuten. Ja, aber ich bin eher so ein Playlist-Typ. Es gibt bei mir nicht einen Künstler, wo ich alles mag und selbst da, wo ich sage, okay, da mache ich den Künstler. Da ist es dann auch so, steht man dann rum und wackelt hin und her. Du wolltest eigentlich so ein Festival, wo die aber alle nur einen Song spielen dürfen. Genau, ja. Ihren besten Song. Ich will einmal Underwater Love und dann irgendwie Kiss from a Rose. Das war's. Und die beiden aber dann 50 Mal spielen, weil ich bin auch jemand, mir ist es dann auch oft nicht genug, den Song einmal zu hören, sondern ich habe oft meine Playlist sind teilweise nur zwei oder drei Songs lang und dann höre ich die einfach immer und immer und immer und wieder. Und da hätte ich gerne ein Konzert, Katie Malure, Seal und wer auch immer Underwater Love gemacht hat. Und die drei dann einfach rotieren immer und kommen immer wieder auf die Bühne und klatschen sich so ab. Ich wollte gerade sagen, du brauchst ein sehr spezielles Festival-Line-Up wahrscheinlich, auch mit sehr weirden Konstellationen, aber ich glaube, Seal und Katie Melua waren schon mal zusammen auf dem Festival. Aber mir kommt gerade eine Idee, Spotify, falls ihr zuhört, das wäre doch mal eine geile Idee. Wir, also Spotify sagt, alle Spotify-User können sich bewerben und der Gewinner kriegt ein Konzert mit den Top-Ten-Titeln, die er gehört hat, nur für ihn. Und es treten nur die Künstler auf, die er in seiner Top-Ten-Liste hat. Egal wie weird es ist, egal wie kontrovers es ist, da ist dann irgendwie Korn, Katie Melua, Lang Lang, Christian Thielemann und Peter Shaw. Und man sagt einfach, jeder kann kommen, aber alle wissen, und der sitzt dann in der Mitte des Saales auf so einem Thron. Riesenthron. Und alle wissen, das ist sein Musikgeschmack gerade. Wir hören das gerade alle an, Bloodhound Gang ist nur wegen dem Typen da. Aber auch spannend, die Ärzte und dann irgendwie böse Onkels in einem Raum zu haben. Oh ja. Das ist auch Konfliktpotenzial. Ja. Aber na ja, hört halt da auf, wo dann halt die Beatles in der Playlist sind und die sagen, was machen wir jetzt? Naja, aber du, denk an ABBA. Denk an ABBA, die Hologrammtechnologie ist mittlerweile so weit fortgeschritten, dass wir mehr oder weniger jeden hier zurückholen können. Und dann kannst du auch den Batman-Song machen, wo dann halt Bart Simpson auf der Bühne steht. Da habe ich jetzt ein bisschen was drüber gelesen, über die Abba-Show. Wir reden von, ich glaube, Abba-Mania oder so. Naja, Voyage. Wie viele Seiten hast du gelesen? Mir fallen zwei Sachen ein. Aber ich glaube, Abba-Mania meint man, glaube ich, mit alles, was im Hype um Abba geht. Und diese Tour heißt Voyage, The Voyage oder so. Okay. Und da geht's Wie viele hast du gelesen? Wie viele Seiten hast du? Ich habe den ganzen Artikel bei Zeit Online gesehen. Wie lange war der? Zwei Seiten wahrscheinlich. Zwei Seiten Artikel gelesen. Ja, okay. So, aber das ist schon zwei Wochen her. Was ich noch weiß. Der Multiplikator, jetzt kann man in die Formel eingehen. Ja, genau. Zwei Seiten, vor zwei Wochen gelesen. Jetzt bleiben noch zwei. Die Stefan-Konstante. Nee, was bei mir hängen geblieben ist, was ich sehr lustig fand, ist, die haben nämlich, also die Idee ist, die wollen nicht mehr auftreten, zum einen, weil die noch nie gerne vor Leuten gespielt haben, zum anderen, weil sie jetzt auch einfach keinen Bock mehr haben. So, und dann haben die da quasi Avatare von sich gebaut, die so hologrammartig, aber du hast natürlich keinen wirklichen Hologramm, das ist noch nicht möglich, sondern du hast einfach so eine Ebene, in der sie sich flat bewegen. Ein grosser Fernseher. Prinzipiell, aber die sind natürlich räumlich aufgeteilt, aber du hast ja keine Bewegung nach vorne, du hast keine Tiefe einfach, aber es sah wohl sehr gut aus, von den Plätzen sieht es einigermaßen futorialistisch aus, und dann haben die aber gesagt, dass beim einen von Björn sah das Avatar am allerbesten aus. Es war auch der, der die Technologie mit den Leuten entwickelt hat. Und sein Avatar sah wahnsinnig, Zitat, jugendlich und frisch aus, wie er da getanzt hat. Und die anderen waren alle so ein bisschen stocksteif und blöde, mit toten Augen. Aber er war, das fand ich so gut. Ja, natürlich, da gibt man, wenn ich Fotos hochlade. Warum hat Björn jetzt so einen Roboterarm eigentlich noch dran? Habe ich doch eigentlich immer gehabt oder nicht? Warum hat er so voller Haare, gar keine Geheimratzeichen mehr und strahlend weisse Zähne. Und das ist dann ein abgefilmtes Konzert oder ist es dann wirklich animiert oder haben die sich einmal aufgenommen und das ist es dann immer wieder, oder wie ist das?
Was ich dachte, wie es wär, ist, die haben sich einmal 3D scannen lassen
und jetzt machen jeden Abend professionelle Schauspieler,
stehen hinten und machen mit Motion-Capturing-Verfahren
ach, verstehe, ja, ja, ja, vorne das Ding.
Ist nicht so. Nee? Nee.
Einfach nur eine Aufnahme.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach eine, ja, präumierte Aufnahme.
Aber was für einen Druck, wenn du weisst, jetzt kommt die Aufnahme und die wird in der ganzen Welt gespielt?
Du kannst ja was verändern.
Ja?
Könntest du sagen, da wo ich dir zugewunken habe und du mich nicht mehr angeguckt hast, können wir da noch mal schneiden?
Entweder mach den Winkel raus oder guck mich an.
Eins von beiden.
Können wir nicht Margaretes Kopf so leicht drehen?
Da haben wir ganz schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht mit Köpfen drehen und alles so. Nee, mach das, damit die mich ansieht. Ich hänge hier mit meinem High Five rum fünf Minuten lang. Einfach so ein paar Details. Ich wurde jetzt auch in Zürich, ich weiß nicht, wie ich davon verraten darf, aber ich wurde von einem Freund, der, ja, der ist da, Mark Madlock, nee, der, ich weiß nicht genau, was ich sagen darf, ich wurde jedenfalls gescannt, 3D gescannt. Und es war wahnsinnig cool. Und ich weiß nicht genau, was ich posten darf. Der arbeitet für sowas, für Motion Capturing und sowas. Moment mal, das heißt, du bist jetzt gecaptured. Das heißt, auf der Live-Show musst du gar nicht mehr mitkommen. Ich werde in Papers zitiert und so. In the long run muss ich nicht mehr mitkommen. Geil. Ich spreche einmal vorher meine Witzchen ein. Ja. Nach Skript. Und dann kommt Thais, die macht das dann und du wirst einfach nur darauf polizieren. Im Hintergrund steht jemand, der muss das dann spielen. Der ist mit so einem Playstation-1-Controller, der dann Stefan steuert einfach so. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Arm hoch, Arm hoch. Dann laufe ich immer so doof in die, weißt du, ein bisschen buggy. Gegen die Wand.
Laufe ich gegen die Wand.
Und ziehst ständig die Waffe. Oh, sorry, sorry, Entschuldigung.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, weil ich musste alle Rechte abtreten für die Wissenschaft.
Und jetzt, glaube ich, tauche ich in so ein paar Papers auf.
Und hast du deinen Bauch angezogen?
Ja, klar.
Weil du da drin stehst in dieser großen Maschine und bist dann angespannt, Muskeln angespannt.
Ja, das ist der Moment.
Und dann, ja, mal gucken, jetzt müssen so Leute in diesem Lab, müssen halt jetzt monatelang mich bepunkten und ausschneiden. Mal gucken. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was daraus wird. Also vielleicht ist es auch einfach, geht es unter, aber vielleicht, weil es gibt ja so ein paar, ich glaube, The Utah Coffee Pot oder so was, es gibt so ein paar Dinge in der Wissenschaft, die auftauchen immer wieder, die man gerne benutzt, die so meme-artig werden. So wie diese Zeitung mit dieser schwarzhaarigen Frau drauf, die immer wieder als Props in verschiedenen Filmen vorkommt und so. Ja, genau. Utah Teapot heißt das. So Dinge, die zum ersten Mal gescannt wurden und so was und dann immer wieder zitiert werden. Genau, der Utah Teapot. Die so die Default-Modelle sind immer wieder. Ja, genau. Die sogenannte Utah-Teekanne gehört zu den ältesten, bekanntesten 3D-Modellen der Computergrafik. Es handelt sich um ein einfaches Oberflächenmodell einer Teekanne. Ja, und deswegen sieht man die dann immer wieder. Ach, stimmt. Weil die halt immer wieder benutzt werden. Ja. Und ich will jetzt, ich will quasi der Utahutta Teapot werden, the Stefan. Aber hast du dann auch Rechte an deinem Bild oder können die machen mit dir, was sie wollen und dann tauchst du irgendwann bei so einer Milchwerbung dann auf oder so, wie du in so einer Milchpot drin sitzt und winkst und du guckst das dann an. Ich mache eine umarmende Geste, ich mache einen High Five, also die haben jetzt nicht so viel von mir. Also aus diesen Gesten können die bislang noch nicht mich mit der Teekanne in der Milch... Naja, High-Fiven geht schon, dass du mit dem Pringles-Mann high-fifst oder so. Das geht schon. Oder mit dem Heckler und Koch-Mann. Hecki. Haubi, die nette Haubitze von dem Mann. Haubi, Haubi von Rheinmetall. Hallo, ich bin Haubi. Aber das-a-piu-piu-piu! Aber das fehlt doch, das fehlt doch diesen Marken. Im Grunde, ja. Weil das machen ja die fünf Fruchtigen, hier die grosse Sternchen, machen das natürlich einigermaßen richtig. Der Pringles-Mann, es gibt den Monopoly-Mann, der genauso aussieht wie der Pringles-Mann, aber es gibt verschiedene Leute, die die Marke greifbarer und sympathisch menschlicher machen. Das fehlt doch Rheinmetall. Rheinmetall braucht doch Rheini. Monsanto, Santi. Santi. Irgendwie so ein kleines Sandpapier, so ein Schleifpapier oder sowas. Weiß ich was genau, nicht genau was. Genscheisse machen die, glaube ich. Ja, ja, aber was passt da gut, so ein Geni. Nee, Mr.DNA, wie bei Jurassic Park gibt es auch dieses kleine DNA-Männischen. Ach so, Mr.DNA, die dann so. Hallo, was ich mache, ist gar nicht gefährlich. Gen-Mais ist nicht so schlimm. Gen-Mais hilft nur, der ist nur gegen Pestizide. Ja, oder halt direkt Cashy. Einfach so ein Batzen Geld. Ich bin Cashy. Ist nicht cool, was ich mache, aber guck mal, wie dick ich bin. Und ich bin immer dicker. Hier, nimm mal einen. Reini fände ich nicht so schlecht. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Es ist die Frage, ob wir jetzt da wieder, also ob wir nicht andere Firmen haben, denen wir vorher helfen sollten, bevor wir Nathan4U-mäßig direkt rein mit... Wir lieben die Herausforderung, wir müssen image-technisch schon an die gehen, die wirklich ein Problem haben. Ja, okay. Hat Nestle nicht auch der, ähm... Nessie. Nessi? Können wir Nessi kaufen? Einmal so in Schottland aufgetaucht, so können wir Nessi haben? Böde, Böde, Böde, nein, nein, nein, nein, Böde, Böde, ne und dann kommt Nessi so hoch mit so einem TM-Zeichen dran, taucht dann wieder auf. Das macht Nessie? Ja, klar. Hört man, immer wenn du in Schottland unterwegs bist, wenn du ganz, ganz, ganz vorsichtig hörst, hörst du immer so ein. So ganz tief unter Wasser. Man hört wahnsinnig gut unter Wasser Dinge. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Nessie, Nessie muss halt wahnsinnig leise sein. Und deswegen glaube ich, wäre ich auch ... Hot Take, ich wäre nicht gern Nessie.
Weil du musst halt die ganze Zeit leise sein. Unter Wasser hörst du extrem gut. Das haben wir mal getestet. Wir fahren ja immer an See, jedes Jahr campen und dann haben wir versucht, auf einer Seite des Sees unter Wasser zwei Steine zusammen zu hauen unter Wasser, auf der anderen Seite hörst du glasklar. Das heißt, die Lärmbelästigung unter Wasser, also Ariel. Das ist der Song, den Ariel gesungen hat.
Under the sea, under the sea. Hey, hallo! Ja, was denn? Ruhe da bitte! Wir singen unseren Song. Wir sind hier mitten im Meeting. The seaweed is always greener in somebody else's lake. Nee, wo sind sie denn da? Hier. Ja, woher ist sie denn hier? Hier beim Notstrom!
Wir sind so weit weg von ihnen! Ja, ich höre jedes Wort! Okay, wir singen leiser. Gut. The seaweed is always green. Hallo! In somebody else's lake. Aber das ist auch ein großes Problem tatsächlich, dass die Schiffe so laut sind, weswegen die Wale sich nicht mehr zurechtfinden. Die Ohren zuhalten die ganze Zeit. Die Evolution hat den Walen
jetzt so ganz große Ohrschoner gegeben.
Das so
eine andere Fischart
hat sich so entwickelt, dass
die in die Ohren der Wale reinschwimmen
und da sich so reinstecken als Symbiose.
Und die Schiffe übersetzt.
Richtig? Ja, damit die Wale
als Piraten die Schiffe dann angreifen. Das denke ich mir, wäre auch ein geiler Film, dass die Wale zurückschlagen. Dass sie die Schiffe kaputt machen, die ganze globalisierte Wirtschaft bricht zusammen, keine Schiffe können mehr fahren. Und der Titel ist Die Lärmbelästigung. Ja. Das Rache. Ja. Und weil die halten sich nicht mehr aus und deswegen attackieren die den Aggressor. Ja. Die attackieren die Schiffe, die zu laut sind. Dezival. Das einzige, was die nur sagen wollen, ist, warte, turn it down. Ja. Es ist ein bisschen zu laut hier, es wird zu laut. Die kommen einfach nur hoch und machen ... Die dann springen, dann in die Luft und in der Luft so ... und dann wieder ins Wasser. Das ist ein echtes Problem, das ist ein echtes Problem. Und jetzt auch, als irgendwie in Kurzzeit wegen Corona mal eine Woche nichts passiert ist, da waren die wirklich so, oh, endlich mal die Ruhe. Da hat man das ganze Meer so ein, oh, geht es auch. Oh, endlich mal. Aber das habt ihr dann, das habe ich gerade gedacht, nämlich, ich kann mich, das ist ein gutes Hobby für dich vielleicht, ich kann mich dich sehr gut vorstellen, draußen in der Natur sitzend, entweder mit einem Fernglas in der Hand Vögel beobachten und dann katalogisieren, wo du welchen Vogel gesehen hast und so und dann kannst du erst so einen großen Vogelalmanach da liegen, mit dem du immer gucken kannst, war das gerade ein Rotmilan oder doch eher ein Schwarzmilan.
Und dann kannst du gucken oder angeln.
Alles auf Rot. Aber angeln natürlich mit der
Ergänzung, dass du
ja kein Fisch isst.
Ja, und du meinst ja,
dann schmeißt man es wieder rein, oder was, was ich das
brutalste überhaupt finde? Nee, nee, nee.
Nee, du reisst die Fische, die du angeln darfst.
Dann reisst man erst die Kiemen auf und dann schmeißt man es wieder rein? Jesus Christ, nein. What, in welcher Ecke willst du mich denken? Ja, ich habe meine Zeit geangelt, tatsächlich. In Ungarn war ich in Urlaub und habe für einen Urlaub geangelt als Kind und habe nichts gefangen. Nein, nur eine ganze Woche lang nichts gefangen. Aber der Weg ist das Ziel, ne? Dafür hattest du so eine Bonding-Experience mit deinem Vater zum Beispiel. Ist das nicht das Liche? Der fand das nicht so gut, dass ich nichts gefangen habe, dass ich nicht die Kosten der Angel wieder reingeholt habe. Der wollte, dass ich so lange Fische verkaufe, bis ich die Angel wieder drin habe. Nein, stimmt nicht. Aber es war tatsächlich, hat einen auf den Boden geholt. Hat einen wirklich auf den Boden geholt. Weil ich dachte, so schwer kann es nicht sein, aber es ist schwer. Ja, auch Feuermachen und so holt einen mehr auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurück. Ja, kannste nicht. Weil jedes Mal denke ich mir bei so Wildlife-Experimenten oder sowas, ja, easy, würde ich überleben und so. Und dann wenn man einmal Feuer in der Natur machen und denkt, ja, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich bin auch zu ängstlich, ich hatte immer Angst, weil du musst ja dann so diesen Haken so hinter dich tun und dann so nach vorne schwingen. Und ich hatte immer Angst, dass der Haken sich irgendwie in meinem Rücken verfängt oder in meinem Ohr oder sowas. Und ich kam da nicht raus. Ich bin da zu ängstlich, zu viele Gedankenbilder in meinem Kopf, dass ich mir immer genau schon vorstelle, der verfängt sich jetzt an meine Ferse und dann reisse ich den mit ganz viel Kraft und dann reisst der einmal meinen gesamten Körper nach oben und dann klappe ich hinten so auf und dann fällt mein Skelett hinten raus, plumpst, und vorne fällt derack. Und du bist wie so ein Fisch an. Du fängst an so Zappeln am Boden, weil du so ein Fisch wie so ein Fisch. Genau, und die anderen Angler kommen und nehmen mich sofort aus und filetieren mich sofort und essen mich auf. Und das hatte ich im Kopf, während ich das gemacht habe. Ich hatte auch brutale Albträume heute, muss ich ganz ehrlich mal sagen. Heute? Absolut brutale Albträume, wirklich furchtbar mit Leuten, die an Stühlen gekettet
waren, mit Sachen, die ich mir aus den Augen
gezogen habe, ganz furchtbar. Aber das
Geile an Albträumen ist ja, du erlebst
die furchtbarsten Sachen, schlimmste
Folter-Albträume und dann wachst du auf,
so, jetzt ein Kaffee,
ein bisschen Fruit Loops und los geht der Tag.
Dein Gehirn macht keinen
Unterschied, dein Gehirn weiss ja,
ob du quasi, also die Gefühle waren ja real. Ja. Und das ist ja die Frage, inwiefern ist was realer oder nicht realer, wenn du etwas siehst und hast ein Gefühl dazu, in der echten Welt, oder du siehst was am Traum und dein Gehirn sagt, Horror, Horror, Horror, ist ja erstmal das Gleiche, im Gehirn das Gleiche. Aber es ist so geil, wie du einfach aufwachst und sagst, ach, reden wir mal grad nicht drüber, dass es hier in so einem Horrorhaus war, irgendwie stundenlang. Oh, schön frisch. Noch mal einmal umdrehen. Sofort weg, sofort egal. Das ist schon verrückt. Ich habe neulich einen fantastischen Traum gehabt, wo ich an dieser Stelle Applaus für mein Unterbewusstsein, weil, und zwar ich irgendwie durch New York gelaufen oder sowas, jedenfalls eine Stadt mit hohen Gebäuden und man hat Prominente gesehen und je prominenter der Mensch war, wurde mir dann erklärt von jemandem, mit dem ich rumgelaufen bin, desto gläserner wird diese Etage, jemand hat so in einer Etage gewohnt. Es gibt ja in New York auch so ein Gebäude, wo du quasi eine ganze Etage hast, ein Apartment ist, so ganz schmale Wolkenkratzer. Und du hast halt hochgeguckt und dann hast du jemanden gesehen und dann wurde mir erklärt, der ist sehr prominent und deswegen wurde jetzt wieder ein Stück in die Betonfassade ersetzt durch Glas. Das heißt, je prominenter ein Mensch ist, desto gläserner wird seine ganze Etage. Aha, bis er ihn alle sehen kann. Genau, und je prominenter, wenn er ganz prominent ist, ist die ganze Etage nur noch Glas.
Man kann in den Asso reingucken, er wird zum gläsernen Menschen. Das fand ich spannend, weil es stimmt ja, ist ja genau so, ist es ja. Aber ist es nicht so, dass je reicher du bist, desto mehr Wände kannst du dir leisten und mehr Privatsphäre kannst du dir leisten? Ja, reicher ja. Je berühmter du bist, desto mehr Person des öffentlichen Lebens du bist, desto weniger kannst du wahrscheinlich fliehen. Ich dachte, ich bin brillant, weil ich hatte, vor allem, ich denke mir so, es gibt ja so verschiedene Therapiemöglichkeiten, wo man auch über seine Träume redet und so, wo man dann das Teil der Therapie ist. So freudianisch. Wo ich mir wirklich denke, wie soll das denn heutzutage funktionieren? Weil allein die Vorstellung, dass ich da so einem 50-jährigen Psychoanalytiker gegenüber sitze und sage, also mein Traum, also ich war Obi-Wan, aber in World of Warcraft. Und es war halt gerade so eine Eventsaison, wo so spezielle Items rumlagen, die man so anklicken konnte. Und dann musste ich so Hinweise sammeln und dann habe ich auf eins und dann war ganz komisch, weil der Cursor war da nicht dieses Zahnrad wie normalerweise, sondern so ein Pergament mit einer Feder, was es eigentlich gar nicht gibt. Er sagt dann so nach zehn Minuten, können wir es noch einmal, wie, World of, Word, Word of, genau, World of Warcraft, genau. Und er ist noch da, aber das stimmt, also das ist ein Spannter-Take, es geht nicht mehr. Wie soll das einordnenbar sein, das kannst du doch vergessen. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, worauf die so achten und so, die können natürlich, das kann man vielleicht schon irgendwie machen, aber allein die Welt, in der das versteht, ich bin Obi-Wan in World of Warcraft, so fair ist es. Und vor allem dann habe ich so Hinweise gefunden, und an die habe ich mich noch versucht zu erinnern, weil die waren nämlich genial, weil die waren nämlich so geschrieben, dass die Wörter links, immer die ersten Buchsterben runtergelesen, das gleiche waren wie nach rechts. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel das erste Wort, sagen wir mal, ist Liebe, so, dann steht Liebe nach rechts geschrieben und das nächste Wort muss dann mit I anfangen, das nächste Wort dann muss mit E anfangen, das nächste Wort dann muss mit B anfangen und E, so dass es nach rechts und nach unten gleich lesbar ist und ich dachte mir, ist ja genial, ist das eine neue Kunstform, die ich entwickelt habe, die mir im Traum gekommen ist. Ich habe natürlich gemerkt, dass es nicht geht, weil du viel mehr Wörter nach unten brauchst als nach rechts und das dann nicht mehr derselbe Text ist. Das ist schön im Traum. Im Traum funktioniert es, weil dein Gefühl macht das in gewisser Weise, weil ich habe auch häufig so Momente, wo ich denke, im Traum, wow, irgendwie ein Rätsel gelöst. Also ich habe das Gefühl, von etwas verstanden zu haben, was total bescheuert ist, weil man ja selber das Regelwerk gebaut hat. Du hast ja selber das Rätsel gebaut, was du dann gelöst hast, worauf du stolz warst. Das heißt, du warst ja sogar noch besser und noch cleverer. Problem ist aber, glaube ich, wenn man das hinterfragt, dieses Rätsel, das ist immer unsinnig, aber das Gefühl, was du hast, das gelöst zu haben, der Stolz, der ist real. Ja, es ist schwierig. Ich dachte wirklich, ich habe da was gefunden, habe mich hingesetzt und wollte das nachkonstruieren. Und dann einfach wieder große Enttäuschung. Und es bleibt nur übrig, dass ich dann dieses Item anklicken wollte mit dem Cursor, aber das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Also da war dann Server-Lag oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet. Weil ich wusste da nicht, vor allem, es gab ja, ich bin ja Kräuterkundler und dann kann ich normalerweise die Kräuter einsammeln, es gab aber dann aufgrund dieses Events dann so besondere Kräuter, die man dann auch noch zusätzlich einsammeln konnte. Und Sie waren Obi-Bahn, Ben? Genau, Obi-Bahn. Sie waren Ben Kenobi. Das Oldschool, ja. Ja, aber weil, also dein Take finde ich sehr, sehr clever. Ist es in unserer hyperkomplexen, durchindividualisierten Welt Traumkunde einfach schlichtweg nicht mehr möglich? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Worauf man da achtet oder so. Weil in der Regel kennt man sich ja auch nicht so gut mit den Details aus, die man, weil wenn du jetzt mit einem, na gut, schwierig. Du musst ja alles kennen. Also du musst ja als Traumdeuterin alles kennen. Schatz, sorry, ich musste jetzt kurz noch die neuesten Folgen von Obi-Wan gucken, weil mein Neuer Klient hört nicht auf, davon zu träumen. Ja, und ich habe jetzt meinen Level-20-Warlock, den ich gerade noch leveln muss. Schatz, du musst dich wirklich den Beruf auch mal im Beruf lassen und du kannst dich den Job noch Job mitnehmen. Nein, ich muss jetzt hier in Schlingendorntal,
ich muss die Löwen töten.
Du warst doch gestern schon im Schlingendorntal.
Ja, aber der hatte Level-60er-Content,
und da bin ich noch nicht.
Und ausserdem weiss ich nicht, wo der Flugpunkt ist.
Schatz, du unterstützt mich auch nie bei den Dingen, die ich mache.
Schatz, du musst wirklich mal einen Cut machen.
Du bist nur noch am Arbeiten.
Vielleicht ist Traumkunde auch einfach ein Scheissjob.
Ja.
Hey.
Hey. Ja, okay.
Vielen Dank. Du bist nur noch am Arbeiten. Vielleicht ist Traumkunde auch einfach ein Scheissjob inzwischen. Hey.
Hey.
Ja, okay.
Ich sag ihm einfach, dass er ein Problem mit seiner Mutter hat.
Ja, so.
Wie es früher gemacht wurde.
Früher haben alle die gleichen Sachen geträumt.
Burg wurde eingenommen.
Burg, Pferd, Pferd, Gold, Stein.
Immer dasselbe. Was lustigerweise gar nicht so weit weg ist von World of Warcraft. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,fen, Pferd, Pferd, Gold, Stein, immer dasselbe. Was lustigerweise gar nicht so weit weg ist von World of Warcraft. Ja, da kommt mir immer wieder zusammen. Da muss man in der Traumkunde wieder in die alten mittelalterlichen Manuskripte schauen. Das ist schwierig. Okay, aber nicht so schlecht. Finde ich einen sehr, sehr guten Punkt. Vielleicht ist jemand von euch das vom Beruf. Ist es noch ein Beruf? Nein, Psychoanalytiker, oder? Ja, doch, gibt es schon noch, auf jeden Fall. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob so viele davon zuhören, ehrlich gesagt. Aber vielleicht, wenn irgendein Patient vom Podcast-UFO redet, ich habe geträumt, dass der Stefan mit mir unterwegs war und dann haben wir Orangensaft getrunken, was komisch ist, weil er hat ja in Folge 138 gesagt, dass er gar keinen Orangensaft mag und auch nicht das mit dem Fruchtfleisch, aber da wollte er dann unbedingt mehr Fruchtfleisch haben, weiss ich nicht, was das bedeuten könnte. Das stimmt. Ich hasse das mit Fruchtfleisch. Also Orangina, das ist gar nichts für dich. Nein. Speist du das angewidert aus oder zwängst du es dir dann doch noch runter? Ich sage, Garçon, Garçon, Garçon, Garçon, Garçon, ja, hier, mein O-Saft, mein O-Saft. Mein O-Saft ist mehr Fruchtfleisch als Flüssigkeit. Weg, weg, weg, weg. So, noch eine Cola? Ja, weil das ist, also neulich war immer irgendwie ein, ich glaube, da war ich halt Brunchen und an einem guten Place, wo man normalerweise richtig guten, frisch gepressten Ohrsoff bekommt, das ist das beste morgens. Aber irgendwie war da jemand dann neu an diesem Mixer und dann kam, was dann da rauskam, war einfach Fruchtfleisch mit ein bisschen Plüssigkeit. Das war prinzipiell aber nicht zu trinken, weil da so Riesenstücke noch drin waren. Du hast schon wirklich ein schweres Leben. Und das war das Schlimmstemste, man muss schon mal sagen, also was du, was passiert ist. Ne, ich weiß. Was du hier Woche für Woche durchmachen. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich das hinkriege. Es ist ja wirklich unglaublich. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Leute haben ja keine Ahnung, was für ein Martyrium du hier Woche für Woche durchmachen. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das überlege. Das ist ja wirklich, das ist eine titanische Leistung, die du immer wieder an den Tag legst, Stefan.
Aber du bist wirklich der Einzige, der das merkt, weil alle anderen sagen immer so, ja, entspann dich mal jetzt mit deinen blöden First World Problems und so. Nee, nee, nee, Stefan, du leidest. Ich sehe dir an, dass du leidest. Ich mache mir auch Sorgen um dich. Mach mal einen Gang runter. Mach mal wirklich einen Gang runter. Ich mach mal einen Gang runter und geh mal vielleicht nicht Brunch. Oh, ich habe letzte Woche die beste Banane meines Lebens gegessen.
Und ich war mir noch nie einer Sache so sicher, wie dass diese Banane das köstlichste Ambrosia war, was auf Erden überhaupt zu finden ist. Es war wirklich eine köstliche Banane, sie war wirklich unfassbar. Hast du sie von einem neuen Ort? Nein, ich habe sie ganz normal, bei Rocket Beans liegt Obst aus und nach der Sendung die Banane schwarz gepunktet. Achtung, wir reden nicht von schwarzen Flecken, schwarzen Bereichen, sondern wirklich einzelne Punkte. Das ist für mich eh schon mal ein Punkt, wo es super war. Und dann wirklich die Banane geschält, keine Spur von diesen Schnüren oder so. Keine blauen Flecken. Die gleitet quasi direkt ab die Schale. Und ich habe diese Banane gegessen und ich habe es erst mal gar nicht realisiert, was da passiert gerade in meinem Gaumenbereich. Ich bin wirklich dann weitergegangen, hatte die Banane schon verzehrt und bin dann wirklich kurz stehen geblieben. Und mir dachte ich, das war köstlich. Wie war das? Also das war wirklich vor allem, da waren ja, und ich denke mir ja, so eine Banane hat ja so einen Reifungsprozess. Und ich glaube, ich habe die wirklich so genailt in genau der Sekunde, weil da sind ja hochkomplexe chemische Dinge, die da stattfinden. Und das ändert sich ja jede Sekunde. Und das heißt, es kann ja wirklich genau einen Moment geben, wo es wirklich perfekt ist. Und ich glaube, ich habe genau in dem Moment reingebissen. Und vor allem das Tolle ist, ich habe mal ein bisschen recherchiert und es gibt auch blaue Bananen, weil ich habe ja mal vor langer Zeit bei Rocket Beans mit Colin diesen Apfeltest gemacht, verschiedene Apfelsorten. Und es gibt ja hundert verschiedene Apfelsorten, die alle anders schmecken. Und da dachte ich mir, geil, aber bei anderen Obstsorten denkt man da überhaupt nicht dran.
Doch, Chiquita. Also wenn jemand sagt so,
bringe mal eine Ananas mit, ja, welche
Ananas denn? Ja, halt eine
Ananas. Oder bei keiner
anderen Obstsorte ist man sich überhaupt
darüber im Klaren, dass es ja natürlich
genauso viele Ananassorten
wahrscheinlich gibt wie Apfelsorten, einfach eine
Million verschiedene und du hast halt eine.
Und deswegen habe ich mal recherchiert, wo gibt es eigentlich noch was zu entdecken und dann habe ich recherchiert die blaue Banane, BB. Die blaue Banane. Die blaue Banane und da hieß es nämlich, die hätte eine Geschmacksnote von Eiscreme. So was Sahniges, Cremiges, also es schmeckt eher wie Bananeneis als Banane und daran habe ich gedacht, weil... Blaue Banane ist eine dicht bevölkerte Zone mit rund 11 Millionen Einwohnern, ein bandförmiger europäischer Grossraum zwischen irischer See und Mittelmeer. Jaja, so. Aber kanntest du die blaue Banane? Ja, das kenne ich schon auch. Aber das ist jetzt egal. Die Banane, die ich verzehrt habe, hatte auch dieses Eisaroma. Die hatte auch dieses cremige, sahnige. Und ich war wirklich hin und weg. Und ich dachte mir wirklich, ich war kurz davor, noch mal umzudrehen, zurückzugehen, um mir mehr von diesen Bananen zu holen. Weil ich dachte, die sind jetzt auf dem Punkt. Die sind auf dem Punkt reif und besser wird es nicht mehr. Und Stefan, ich muss sagen, wir sind beide auch nicht mehr die Jüngsten.
Ich glaube, ab einem gewissen Punkt kann man wirklich anfangen, von den Besten meines Lebens zu sprechen. Weil wir haben jetzt ein gutes Teil unseres Lebens hinter uns. Du kannst auch vorher vom Besten deines Lebens sprechen, es ist halt noch nicht empirisch wirklich. Du hast ja nicht die Zahlen. Ich möchte schon, wenn ich das sage, dass das auch eine gewisse Bewandtnis hat. Und bei mir war es wirklich diese, ja, ich kann mir wirklich beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen,
nochmal eine bessere Banane zu essen. Es kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen darauf an, wie gut deine Tagesform war. Bis dahin schlecht, ab dann gut. Hunger ist ja der beste Koch. Ne?
Und da muss man auch sagen,
schmeiss die T-Shirt-Presse an,
Stefan Tietze hat wieder die Feder geschwungen. Hunger ist ja der beste Koch. Man muss ja sagen, also in dem Moment, wo du sehr viel Hunger hattest und nach dem anstrengenden Studiotag dir was auch immer schnappst aus diesem Obstkorb, da kann ja auch noch ein Kinderbueno liegen oder ein Apfel. Das wäre vielleicht auch jeweils das beste Kinderbueno-Apfel des Lebens gewesen. Stefan, ich sehe in deinen Augen, du hast noch nicht realisiert, was da passiert ist letzte Woche. Ich habe wirklich den Himmel gekostet. Ich habe wirklich in das Fundament des Universums gebissen. Warst du gut gelaunt an dem Moment? Feierabend, jetzt geht's nach Hause, schön Drive-to-survive gucken. Ja, nicht besser als sonst eigentlich. Es war wirklich so, vor allem, also das ist ja das, man hat ja bei jeder, jedes Nahrungsstück hat ja so eine Range an, wie gut es schmecken kann. Wie schmeckt ein guter Apfel, wie schmeckt ein schlechter Apfel. Gutes Stück Schokolade, schlechtes Stück Schokolade.
Mag ich überhaupt Apfel?
Genau, so und bei jedem Menschen sind diese dann je nachdem verschoben, je mehr man sie mag.
Wie so ein Hammer, diese Widerstands, wie nennt man diese Grafiken? Ja, ja, Hammer.
Ja, genau.
So wie bei so einer komischen, weirden Waage, wo man dann so den Bereich angeben muss mit diesen beiden Stücken.
Und man hat ja bei jedem, also wenn du jetzt in ein Restaurant gehst und du isst ein richtig gutes Huhn, dann hast du im Kopf, wie schmeckt das beste Huhn der Welt, wie schmeckt normalerweise ein Huhn, jetzt nochmal 20, 30 Prozent oben drauf, so. Und diese Banane hat meine Skala so absolut gesprengt, also da war wirklich, das war wirklich einfach ein Kategorienfehler mal 10, so wurde wirklich ganz woanders auf der Skala plötzlich aufbiss, wo du denkst, das ist ein Messfehler oder es ist keine Banane gewesen, das war wirklich ein Kategorienfehler mal 10, wo du wirklich ganz woanders auf der Skala plötzlich aufbiss, wo du denkst, das ist ein Messfehler oder es ist keine Banane gewesen, das war wirklich ein Messfehler oder es ist keine Banane gewesen, das war wirklich ein Kategorienfehler mal 10, wo du wirklich ganz woanders auf der Skala plötzlich aufbiss, wo du denkst, das ist ein Messfehler oder es ist keine Banane gewesen. Das war wirklich ganz woanders. Was hast du vorher gegessen? Versuchst du, was ich machen will? Du willst den Kontext aufmachen, ich verstehe das, aber das zeigt mir noch ein bisschen deine Naivität, dass du noch nicht verstanden hast, was das für ein Jahrhundertereignis war. Mein Biss in diese Banane, was das für ein köstliches Dessert war. Naja, ich glaube halt ... Du versuchst es zu verstehen. Ich hingegen glaube an das Wunder. Jaja, du glaubst. Ich forsche gerade. Genau, aber das ist noch unser Unterschied. Ich war ja nicht dabei. Angenommen, jemand wäre daneben gestanden, du hättest ihm oder ihr was gegeben, dann, wie hätte die Person reagiert? Hätte die auch gesagt, holy shit, das ist die beste, das sprengt meine Bananenskala. Ich hab's nämlich dann im Firmen-Slack geschrieben, Leute, greift bitte zu, das sind die besten Male an der Welt. Weil ich war schon zu Hause, aber ich dachte mir, das ist jetzt, ich hab wirklich mit mir gerungen und hab gesagt, nein, ich kann das jetzt nicht zulassen, dass diese Bananen vergehen, weil die sind gerade auf dem Punkt. Habe ich in Slack geschrieben, Firmen Slack, eine Kollegin antwortet und meinte, na, die sind nur noch für Bananenmilch gut. Die hat sofort gesagt, die sind überreif, die sind nichts für mich und dann dachte ich mir, okay, vielleicht... Bananenmilch oder Bananenbrot? Bananenmilch, so, also anscheinend ist ihre These, dass wenn Bananen zu reif sind, kann man dann nur noch Bananenmilch damit machen. Genau, Leute backen dann Bananenbrot. So, und deswegen glaube ich, dass dieser Moment mit der Banane und mir einfach so der perfekte Schnittpunkt zwischen meinem Anspruch und der Banane selber war, dass ja jeder Mensch einen anderen Punkt hat. Und ich glaube, das war wirklich genau unser Match. Den hast du genailt. Den habe ich wirklich einfach genailt, aber auf einen Zentimeter. Auf die Minute vielleicht sogar. Vielleicht hat jeder Mensch ja so eine Minute für jede Banane, wo sie genau passt, aber man verpasst die halt immer wieder. Heißt aber auch, und was man dafür auch braucht, ist ein gewisses Bedürfnis an diesem Geschmack. Also ich sag mal, wenn du jetzt kein grosser Bananen-Affizionado gewesen wärst, dann wäre es vielleicht kein großes Ereignis für dich gewesen, den Schnittpunkt zu treffen. Ich bin zum Beispiel kein großer Fan von Melonen. Wahrscheinlich habe ich aber schon mal den perfekten Zeitpunkt mit der perfekten Melone gehabt, konnte ihn aber nicht wertschätzen, weil selbst die beste Melone für mich nur so ein Moment ist. Ja, oder dein Melonenpunkt ist so weit weg von dem der anderen, dass du immer nur Melonen serviert bekommen hast, wo andere Leute dachten, die wäre gut für dich, weil sie von ihrem eigenen Parameter ausgehen. Du bräuchtest aber eine, die für die Reifer wert ist. Für mich ist die schlechteste Himbeere immer noch sehr viel besser als die beste Melone. Da muss man, glaube ich, in dieser Range muss man denken. Ich glaube, du wirst diese Aussage zurücknehmen eines Tages. Ich glaube, eines Tages sitzt du hier mit ganz kleinen Äuglein, mit ganz, ganz kleinen Hosentaschen und sagst, ich muss mich nochmal korrigieren, ich muss nochmal zurück, Folge 313, übrigens die Gift-Hotline, äh, 313313, ist ein anderes Thema. Nee, ist ein wichtiges Thema, bin mir recht. Willst du da nochmal zurücknehmen und sagst, ich hab die Melone gekostet, die für mich einfach das Beste ist. Weil da hat sich für mich, mir hat da echt eine Welt aufgesprengt, weil ich dachte mir ab dann, okay, anscheinend ist mein Blick auf Nahrung falsch, anscheinend sind diese Bereiche viel grösser und ab jetzt denke ich mir so, ich will gar nicht so das beste Rib-Eye-Steak oder da so dieses superkrasse japanische Filet oder irgendwie sowas, diese ganz krassen Sachen, sondern mein Ziel ist ab jetzt, ich will die beste Gurke essen, so die bestmögliche Gurke, weil wenn der Abstand zwischen der Normalbanane und der Ambrosia-Banane schon so enorm war, wie schmeckt die beste Karotte der Welt, so die einfach perfekt ist. Naja, es ist nicht so leicht zu übertragen, weil Bananen natürlich noch ein bisschen empfindlicher sind auf ihrer Umwelt. Genau, die haben so diese Zeitkomponente, diese Reifung.
Und man kann denen ja zugucken, wie sie kaputt gehen. Also man kann ja zugucken, wie sie jeden Tag immer schwärzer werden, bis sie irgendwann einfach so ein braun-schwarzes Ekelding sind und die auch nicht mehr gut für Bananenbrot sind. Okay. Und man kann sie ja kaufen, wo sie lächerlich unreif sind. Das heißt, es gibt ja nicht so viele andere Dinge, die so dermassen schnell noch altern. Von daher ja, aber ich wünsche viel Erfolg bei der Gurkensuche. Ja, was ist, also ist die beste Gurke, also wo du sagst, ich finde das eine gute Aussage, die beste Himbeere ist schlechter als die beste Melone. Ist jetzt wirklich die beste Karotte der Welt besser als das schlechteste Chicken Nugget oder sowas? Also, wie weit reichen die da ein? Können wir mal einmal ultimativ Obst und Gemüse ranken? Was ist beste Obst? Was ist beste Gemüse? Schwierig, schwierig. Nee. Weil ich glaube, die beste Banane ist in Welten, Welten, Welten, Welten besser als die beste Melone. Du kriegst keine Melone jemals so gut wie die beste Banane. Was ist mit der Mango zum Beispiel? Die Mango ist auch einfach top tier. Super. Anderes Thema. Auch super. Aber die beste Mango ist die Mango. Vor allem, ich bin ja seit diesem großen Apfeltest, wo ich wirklich auch geschmeckt habe, dass es grosse Unterschiede zwischen verschiedenen Apfelsorten gibt, bin ich ja eigentlich weg von diesem Denken in Obst-Kategorien. Weil ab jetzt, wenn du immer sagst, ich mag Bananen, frage ich, welche Bananen? Welche der vielen Sorte? Du hast es geschafft, noch ein bisschen unangenehmer in privaten Gesprächen zu werden. Genau, weil auch hier, vielleicht ist die beste Bananensorte, also für dich wieder, vielleicht gibt es eine Melonensorte, die besser ist als die beste Himbeere der schlechtesten Himbeersorte. Verstehst du, dass es innerhalb dieser Kategorien auch nochmal Abstufungen gibt? Da bist du ja blind. Du gehst ja wirklich Himbeerenmampfen durch die Welt, stopfst dir das rein, aber hast gar keine Ahnung, welche Sorte du da überhaupt bist. Wir haben übrigens ein lustiges Bild bekommen, weil wir hatten es ja neulich von Slush-Eis-Sorten. Ja, da hatten wir es von. War das nicht schön, als wir es davon hatten? Ich sag das nie so, aber alle sagen es so. Jetzt habe ich es einmal benutzt, ich werde darauf angesprochen. Weil ich hasse das, ich hasse das, wir hatten es doch davon. Ja. Finde ich so doof. Wir haben noch darüber gesprochen, so viel Zeit muss ja auch sein. Ja. Wir hatten noch verhandelt, wie verschiedene Sorten, genau, bei Pazlashi da vorhanden sind und wir hatten die Idee, dass man vielleicht eine Farbe nimmt für immer zum Beispiel Rot, für alle Sachen, die es gibt, für Schlumpffarbe, für Schlumpfgeschmacksrichtung, Waldmeister, Kirsche, however. Und jetzt hat ein Zuhörer eines Zuhörerinnen gefunden, dass der blaue Slushie, die blaue Slush-Eissorte, die wir beide als Schlumpf-Schlush-Blaubeere beschrieben haben, beschrieben wurde als blaue Himbeere. Und das habe ich schon häufiger gesehen jetzt. Blaue Himbeere. Wow. Und ich finde, es stimmt. Ja. Gibt es nicht. Aber ja. Aber mittlerweile durch dieses ganze Farbstoffsystem, durch Süssigkeiten hat man schon das Gefühl, dass Farben eine Geschmacksrichtung haben. Also wenn du sagst, das schmeckt so wie eine blaue Himbeere, kann ich mir was darunter vorstellen. Ja, ich mir auch. Es hat nämlich genau diesen Blaubeeren, Heidelbeer, Johannisbeer, ist das alles das gleiche, Kram mit drin, aber auch diese Spitze, wie eine, stumpf, genau, aber wenn du dir den Equalizer vorstellst, du hast diese Himbeerfruchtigkeit, diese Fruchtenspitzen, die hast du mit drin. Aber du hast auch ein bisschen dieses blaue Powerade, dieses blaue Rate. Ja, genau. Hast du auch so ein bisschen, dass es halt auch eine Farbe ist.
Ja, ja, genau.
Aber es stimmt schon, ja. Ach so, auch. Ja, ja. Und deswegen, das fand ich eine sehr gute Beschreibung, blaue Himbeere. Das heißt, wir trennen uns inzwischen von echten Dingen, die es gibt. Ja. Da gibt es blaue Himbeeren. Es gibt auch blaue Bananen. Kann gut sein, blaue Bananen. Aber ich habe letztens ein tolles Video gesehen von einer Geschmacksexpertin, die im Taste-Business arbeitet und die hat auch so ein bisschen erzählt, dass es zum Beispiel viele Süßigkeiten gibt, Fruit Pebbles zum Beispiel, kennt man in Deutschland vielleicht nicht, aber die schmecken alle gleich, haben aber unterschiedliche Farben und die werden von den Konsumenten wahrgenommen als Farben haben unterschiedliche Geschmäcker. Einfach, weil wenn du ein blaues Fruit Pebble, die heißen ja Fruchtklotz, dann isst, erwartest du einen anderen Geschmack. Und dann schmeckt dein Gehirn auch was anderes, als wenn du sagst, das ist unterschiedlich. Das heißt, man muss die gar nicht unterschiedlich schmecken lassen, sondern der Kunde assoziiert automatisch zu anderen Farben auch andere Geschmäckter. Das ist ja irrespannend. Das ist auch so, hier, Blue Raspberry Flavor. Gibt es nämlich, im Englischen gibt es sogar so einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu. Blue Raspberry is a manufactured flavoring and food coloring for candies, snack foods, syrups and soft drinks. The flavor and color do not derive from any species of raspberry. Das heißt, es ist wirklich einfach nur künstlich, aber damit sich, weil alle sich was darunter vorstellen können, blue raspberry, ist das jetzt einfach ein Geschmack. Das finde ich super spannend. Aber das ist ja so wie Geschmack 2.0. Also es ist ja wirklich Lebensmittelindustrie 2.0. Es ist echt abgefahren. Schaut euch das an, bei Wired ist das Taste Expert. Gebt das mal ein, weil es gibt nämlich auch Supertaster. Es gibt Menschen, die können einfach intensiver schmecken als andere und sie zeigt auch einen Test, wie man rausfinden kann, ob man Supertaster ist und zwar indem man einfach die Geschmacksknospen auf der Zunge zählt. Man macht so ein einheitliches Locherloch, das legt man auf die Zunge, dann macht man ein Foto von seiner Zunge und dann zählt man, wie viele Geschmacksknospen innerhalb von diesem Loch sind und wenn es grösser als eine gewisse Zahl ist, dann ist man ein Super-Taster. Könnt ihr zu Hause einfach ausprobieren. Und wenn ihr Super-Taster seid, dann habt ihr vielleicht eine grosse Karriere in der Welt von Taste vor euch und könnt... Das schmeckt geil. Stell dir vor, das könnte man mit Intellekt machen. Ja, dass man einfach zählt, einfach guckt, wie es ist.
Genau, du machst einfach durchs Ohr, machst ein Foto von deinem Gehirn.
Genau, und das wird so viel verändern. Das wird alles verändern.
Würde man das selber machen bei sich.
Es wird zu einem Elitismuskreis führen, weisst du, so eine Staatsform,
wie heisst das, Aristokratie.
Es würde, also wenn du ...
Sapiokratie, wo die Schlauen herrschen. Ja, genau. Du würdest halt, plötzlich wird sich alles verändern. Ja, vielleicht verändert sich das auch, wenn wir alle plötzlich wissen, wie viele Geschmacksknospen wir haben. Ich glaube, ich habe ganz wenig. Ich habe ganz wenig, die richtig hart rangenommen werden müssen, damit die überhaupt was schmecken. Ich brauche ganz viel Zucker, ganz viel Frucht. Ich glaube, ich habe wirklich so Bocksack Geschmacksnerven, wo man so richtig reindonnern muss, damit da was passiert, wo wirklich dann einmal eine Jahrhundertbanane vielleicht da mal irgendwie so halbwegs da was wegkitzelt. Was ich aber auch gefunden habe, eine geniale Idee, geniale Idee, und zwar sind es Bananen, die verkauft werden, und zwar du hast immer fünf Bananen zusammen in unterschiedlichen Reifungskamen. Also du hast wirklich die ganz grünen... So ein Testkit. Genau, so ein Testkit. Und es ist genial, weil du sonst ja immer das Problem hast, dass der ganze Buschel gleichzeitig reif wird. Du bräuchst so einen Farbgesekt, so einen Farbcode, weißt du, was man so wie ein Fächer aufmachen kann. Ja, genau, wie so Tapeten. Genau, da kannst du genau sehen und dann musst du einmal die durchprobieren. Das können wir mal rausbringen. Heißt das Podcast-Ufo? Ja ist ein kleiner Fächer, kannst du aufdrehen und dann hast du verschiedene Reifungsgrade von Bananen. Auch wie dann die Punkte langsam kommen und so, und es langsam dunkler wird. Bisher fängt es an bei leicht grün noch, so Leimfarben. Dann machst du ein Kreuz bei Dingen, was du am meisten magst. Dann kannst du immer mit diesem Ding rumgehen. Weißt du, was wir machen? Wir machen eine App. Und zwar machst du so, wenn du die Banane kaufst, machst du ein Foto von der Banane und dann musst du halt so ein bisschen einstellen, wie du die gerne magst und deine App sagt irgendwann, bieb, bieb, jetzt ist die Banane perfekt, dann kannst du die jetzt aufessen und dann kannst du dann eingeben, war die gut oder war die schlecht, war die zu reif, war die zu roh? Was heißt das Gegenteil von reif? Unreif. Roh. So, und dann kannst du immer sagen, wo war die perfekt? Und so tastet sich die App langsam ran. Ich meine, das ist natürlich nervig, weil du immer ein Sklave der App bist, wann du die Banane isst und nicht dann, wenn du sie essen willst. Und was wir alles mit den Daten anfangen können. Ich meine, alle App-Hersteller sammeln so die coolsten Daten der Welt und wir sammeln, wie Leute ihre Bananen am liebsten mögen. Warum kostet denn die App nichts? Ach, ach, die machen wir nur aus Rheinland. Und dann gehen wir sie zu Google. Ja, wir haben frische Daten. Was habt ihr denn? Aufenthaltsort? Bananendaten. Wie schlecht Bananendaten? Wir haben eine Menge, da haben Sie richtig gehört, eine Menge Bananendaten.
Was haben wir denn mit Bananendaten?
Wir wissen alles über Bananen.
Nee, wirklich, wir wissen alles über Bananen.
Also wie die Leute die wollen, also welchem Reifegrad und wir mit inzwischen so Hunderttausend.
Aufenthaltsort oder irgendwie wie viel Geld die ausgeben?
Nee, aber so ob die Leute lieber es mögen, wenn die schon ein paar Punkte haben oder nicht.
Okay, Religion oder politische Ausrichtung? Nee, also Bananendaten, also alles eher zu Bananen. Kann ich noch einen Kaffee haben? Ich habe das Gefühl, das Meeting ist gleich vorbei, und ich will jetzt noch einen Kaffee haben. Damit das Meeting noch länger dauern muss, damit ich diesen brühen, heißen Kaffee noch zehn Minuten länger... Dann kriegt man so ein lauwarmes, man tut auch trotzdem, weil es wieder heiß ist.
Kaffee ist das schlechteste Getränk, um sich zu treffen, bei Meetings, bei Gesprächen,
weil bei so einem Glas Wasser kann man sagen, so, Gespräch beendet, man äckst das Glas Wasser, fertig.
Aber bei Kaffee ist immer so, ja, sie sind dann entlassen.
Man rührt dann so um. Einen Löffel noch. Kann ich noch die Milch noch mal haben, bitte? Ja. Meine Mutter war lange Personalleiterin, also HR Director, und sie hatte tatsächlich klischeehaft immer für Gespräche, wo sie jemanden entlassen musste, eine Taschentuchbox, hat es mir mal irgendwann erzählt, in ihrem Büro. Das war einfach so eine Grundequipment, eine Taschentuchbox, die man dann irgendwann hinstellt. Und ich habe sie mal irgendwann gefragt, was ist das denn für ein wahnsinnig unangenehmer Moment? Also klar, es ist wahnsinnig furchtbar, wenn dann da jemand weint, aber trotzdem hätte ich doch niemals das Selbstbewusstsein, irgendwann so eine Box zu nehmen und die in die Mitte zu stellen. So, weil es sagt ja auch, yeah, well, this happens. Ja. Und du gehst jetzt gleich kaputt. Das habe ich schon, das habe ich, ja, oder genau, wenn halt der Gegenüber, die Gegenüber schon anfängt zu weinen, ist ja auch furchtbar schlimm, das zu nehmen, diese Box und auf den Tisch zu stellen, weil es sagt ja auch, ich war darauf vorbereitet. Du bist ja auch nicht die Erste, die hier war. Nee, das ist einkalkuliert. Das ist Teil des Systems. Das macht ja alles noch viel schlimmer. Ist aber auch ein geiler Move, den man mal so einfach random in anderen Situationen bringen kann. Wenn man irgendwie mit jemandem was beredet und dann einfach mal ohne Kommentar so eine Taschentuch auf den Tisch legt, einfach so als okay, alles klar, ja, was willst du mir gleich sagen? Ja, genau so, und die andere Person, ich wollte mit dir mal über unsere Zahlen sprechen, und dann genau so, so eine Taschentuchbox auf den Tisch, und du so, hä, wie, was, wie, was kommt jetzt? Du, wollen wir mal wieder eine Serie zusammenschauen? Also eine traurige. Okay. Was ist auf dieser Box drauf? Also sind da lächelnde Menschen drauf oder sind da Hasen drauf? Wer designt sowas? Das war jetzt nicht gefragt. Naja, Taschentuchboxen sind eh mega weird. Ich bin ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Gefangener meiner toxischen Männlichkeit und kaufe dann Taschentuchboxen, die so ein bisschen, weiß nicht, so einen Weltallhintergrund oder haben. Weil es gibt ja, wenn man Taschentuchboxen kauft, verschiedene, die sind alle von der gleichen Marke, aber die haben alle verschiedene Verpackungen, alle verschiedene Farbe Kartons. Man weint ja aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Anlässen. Genau, manche sind halt so sehr blau. Steht dann auch so drauf, Trauer, Verzweiflung, niedriges Selbstbewusstsein, Film ... Ausgedehnte Jerking-off-Session, Swinker-Smiley ... Swinker-Smiley. Genau, und ich hab dann so einen Weltall-Hintergrund genommen, wo ich auch dachte, das ist so klischeehaft.
Weil man sich so klein fühlt in dem Weltall oder was.
Deswegen kann man dann weinen.
Ja, das Eintaschtuch von vielen.
Ich bin nur ein Sandkorn im grossen Stall.
Nee, weil es so halb männlich war oder so, und dann war es einfach so ein Chrom-Hintergrund.
Wow.
Und ich habe mir so, warum nimmt man denn das?
Ja, aber.
Wenn du so hart wärst, würdest du nicht weinen, Stefan.
Ja, genau.
Ja, es ist so für weinende Männer, die dann trotzdem sich noch ein bisschen Spur männlicher halten wollen. Ich will mich männlich fühlen, auch wenn ich weine. Auch wenn ich scheiße. Das sind männliche Tränen, nur dass ihr es wisst. Ja, genau. Nur dass ihr es wisst. Ich weine, weil mein neuer Mustang, die Lackierung ist so toll. So, nämlich. Aber es ist so blöd, aber man nimmt dann nicht, ich nehme das nicht, die pinke Plaschentuch. Und ich weiß auch nicht, was ich gemacht hätte, wenn es jetzt nur die pinke noch gegeben hätte. Aber warum holst du überhaupt so eine Box? Bist du unzufrieden mit den normalen Taschentuchpackungen? Die finde ich doof. Sehr, sehr viel Plastikkopfer, so eine Zack, Zack, Zack, wo man dann auch immer so gut mehrere rauszupfen kann, wenn man weiß, oh, jetzt wird es... Aber zu Hause habe ich da so ein Taschentuch-Box stehen für meine obligatorischen Niesanfälle. Jetzt wird gerade im Sommer auch wieder ein großes Problem für die vielen Tränen und für die vielen Entlassungsgespräche, die ich führen muss. Und deswegen lieber eine Box. Ist auch, glaube ich, umweltschonder. Die sehen auch alles, ne? Die sehen deine Höhen, die sehen deine Tiefen und die sehen eine Menge YouPorn auf jeden Fall. Die Taschenbuchhersteller, die kriegen alles mit. Ja,
die wissen alles, die wissen wirklich alles.
Okay, ja,
Leute, dann damit entlassen wir euch.
Haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine schöne
Woche und
viel Spaß beim Einkauf und
schreibt mal, was war das Beste, was
ihr je gegessen habt und warum war es
so gut und warum war es auf dem Punkt?
Ja, und dann brauchen wir einen Programmierer, eine Programmiererin für unsere Bananen-App.
Für die, das Podcast-UFO-App, für die Bananen-App. Das ist, glaube ich, ein grosser Erfolg.
Ansonsten haut rein, macht's gut. Wir steigen ein, frisch gestärkt und heem ab.